[Music]
so when it comes to some of that
third-party content that you might want
to share make sure that you realize it's
more about just white papers and guides
that it's also insightful thought
leaders its breaking news and trend
reports maybe with a little bit of your
own commentary on how you think you know
this might factor in broader solutions
and tests now when you look at the
feedback channel between marketing and
cents first we're going to start by
looking at how marketing can support
sales and basically a lot of this boils
down to the idea that the easier you
make it to leverage the content that
your team is producing internally the
more time they can spend making those
connections in selling your products so
prepare the content that they need and
deliver it there's a lot of different
ways to do that one of them is the idea
of setting up something internally where
you've got a weekly email that's going
out to your sales team saying but here's
the content snippets and lengths that
are relevant to the industry this week
that maybe tie into some different
pieces of collateral we've prepared and
here's the format if you want to share
it to Facebook and you share it to
LinkedIn and you want to share it to
Twitter have it ready to go for a cut
and paste so that your sales team can
quickly and easily get into the networks
where they're connecting these people
and share that content also a fist your
sales team and writing and building
stronger social profiles especially on
something like LinkedIn or something
like aura where it might really be about
making some of those connections in
building a credibility
make sure that you are supplying
guidelines on writing great posts and
updates so that if they're going past
what you might be providing with a
snippet that they've still really got
something excellent that they can work
with if they're understanding you know
down on Facebook you want to make sure
that you're putting that question in
place on LinkedIn you've got room for
longer form content and you know maybe
for writing a full article and getting
it up there but help educate your sales
team and how they can most effectively
use each of these different channels and
then share data with them on which posts
are producing stronger leads and shares
because they may have a favorite piece
of content that they so like really
really hits mark but maybe it doesn't
convert maybe it doesn't lead people to
that next stage in the in the buying
cycle or in the sewing cycle so it's
important to get some of that data out
there to let them know which pieces of
collateral tend to have the highest
success rate so that they can make sure
they're working the strongest piece of
content you have now on the flip side of
that when we when we look at how sales
can support marketing a lot of this
comes back to feedback because marketing
has the ability to leverage analytics
and that's really important because the
marketing team can know again where the
conversion rates are with the drop off
points but the sales team has a little
bit more intimate knowledge where the
tipping points are and with the pushback
tends to come from because they engage
in those conversations that don't always
get translated into sort of that click
here click there Internet activity so
your sales team can also be emailing
marketing weekly saying look here's the
news here's the trends here's the
concerns that are being shared you know
here's the top three push backs that I
got from people or here's you know the
top two new feature requests that we
have that I know we're working on but
you know maybe we don't have any content
that addresses it make marketing aware
of potential influencers or evangelist
this one is really important especially
if you rely heavily on influencer
marketing a lot of times the sales team
is going to have contact with people
that are maybe at a huge company that
just absolutely love your products and
services and really enthusiastic about
it and marketing they have no idea that
those people are that excited so when
you're doing your follow-up
you're understanding hey this is someone
that really could be a great testimonial
or maybe a great case study there's the
opportunity for the sales team to make
that connection
the marketing team also pasul and
contact with happy customers again for
case studies and testimonials you know
maybe just on the snippet or the
soundbite side of things and then share
personal experience on which batches of
leads tend to be the warmest or convert
the best
maybe you got leads in from a specific
white paper or maybe leads came in from
a webinar that you know there's a
company put on and you find that they're
really they're targeted and they're
really performing well again let the
sales team know this piece of collateral
or this part of inbound marketing really
created a great list of regional and
really having a lot of success with it
now sales also needs to be out there
participating in conversation now that
might be on LinkedIn it might be kora
may be an industry forum but basically
getting sales out and active where
prospects are asking questions it's
critical and it doesn't mean that your
sales team should be spending all the
time in social media prospecting there's
clearly got to be an internal balance
based on what what's best for each
individual company but again equipping
them to be out on these sites where they
can answer questions where they can
build some credibility and help build
the brand is really critical so
marketing really needs to enable that
type of conversation whether it means
you're sharing traffic referral data
conversation monitoring or you simply
have a point person that knows what all
of your content is is available and is
doing you know maybe some social
listening online to identify places
where there's an opening to get involved
in the conversation those communication
channels have to happen and the most
successful sales teams right now in a
social world are the ones that have
already figured this out and are
integrating seamlessly with the
marketing team
if marketing and sales are kind of you
know wrapping their arms around the
individual prospects going know this
prospect is mine I brought them in and
I'm going to see them to completion
things aren't going to work as smoothly
as if they need to
and so there really needs to be at a lot
of companies a change in focus to say
how do we make sure that we're making
this information easily accessible and
sometimes especially with enterprise
companies that means almost putting
together an internal like content
repository that you know where content
is tagged or archived or structured by
different stages the buying cycle or by
different keywords so that the sales
team can quickly go in and look and say
okay what what piece of collateral do we
have through the video on this topic is
it ready to go if you don't have the
ability to have something in sort of
that high-tech in place you at least
need to have the doors open conversation
so that your sales team can come to
someone on your marketing team that
really understands yes here's all the
content and put together there we have
that and they look for it if I can find
it and get you the latest any possible
now I've mentioned the sales funnel
concept several kinds of being aware of
what that looks like now pretty much
every Enterprise sales team I've ever
worked with has this in place but it's
not always communicated properly to the
content marketing team so that they can
look and say okay here's what we're
trying to do we're trying to accomplish
and sort of the customer journey because
they move through the process to
eventually become a customer you know if
they're in that that guide stage where
they're assessing risk and we're trying
to build confidence okay there's a
different type of content that you need
to have built for that specific section
so making sure you have that internal
cycle and making sure that sales is
working with marketing so everyone
understands what kind of content needs
to be offered at that stage is really
critical and then also keep in mind as I
mentioned earlier sales and PR are
sorting of best champions your marketing
team has at identifying some of those
brand advocates that really come into
play once someone has closed and had the
opportunity to really experience you
know the service or the product that you
come in offers so leveraging those
relationships on the brand advocate side
and looking at building evangelists or
improves their outreach or even just
seed points or feedback points this is
really a critical part of your ongoing
marketing efforts
so wrapping this up is really about a
symbiotic relationship sales and
marketing have always worked together on
some fronts but social selling really
requires a different approach and a
different level of partnership and
communication so if this is an area that
your company not really working strongly
on right now you need to take the time
to have some people who sales and people
who market and sit down and really talk
about how you can help each other and
what it looks like to kind of go through
that testing and measuring kind of
working out all the details process your
key takeaways from this video are
creating a regular contact cycle between
your sales and marketing team to allow
your sales team access to the freshest
in this accurate collateral each stage
of the sales cycle also in posting the
social channels it's important to
balance sales content with purely
educational profitable content making
sure some third-party content thrown in
there as well number three outlining
your sales cycle is a critical really a
crucial part of identifying potential
gaps and collateral that need to be
created by your content marketing team
also your sales team is often the
best-equipped staff your marketing team
really understand things like tipping
points and points of concern that might
keep people from making the move into
the next stage of the cycle so gather
that information and really be set
knowledge wisely and then finally your
sales team is going to be a PR team
greatest at best when it comes to
identifying potential evangelists and
influencers make sure that they're
communicating regularly with your
marketing unique PR team this concludes
lesson two how sales and marketing
function as a team in social selling
with that we come to the end of section
nine social media selling thank you so
much for joining in this section
[Music]
Hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here